wir müssen aufpassen dass gerade in
dieser sensiblen zeit der richtige ton
getroffen wird
denn es ist gerade eine aufgewühlte zeit
und da glaube ich stehen auch die
schauspieler da schon die künstler in
verantwortung weil sie ganz genau wissen
wie ihre worte ihre gesten wirken es ist
natürlich überzogen gewesen ironisch
zynisch aber man muss in deutschland die
meinung äußern können und ohne dass man
gleich bedroht oder angeht so massiv
unter druck gesetzt wird also das finde
ich das geht gar nicht die reaktionen
auf diese videos waren ja massiv auch
schon bei twitter bei facebook bei
instagram und haben jeden angemessenen
ton vermissen lassen das heißt müsste
man nicht viel schärfer diese art von
shit storm von morddrohungen
mittlerweile kritisiert die finde ich
völlig indiskutabel das finde ich ihn
also indiskutabel wenn autos von
politikern in brand gesetzt werden wir
politisch nicht mit ihnen einverstanden
ist und ist komplett unmöglich wenn
rundfunkräte berufsverbote fordern für
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler die
sich hier geäußert haben das geht gar
nicht und schon gar nicht im
demokratischen verbundsystem will das
sagen pro frau becker natürlich geht das
nicht morddrohung kein niemals in
unserer demokratie kann hass gewalt oder
bedrohung 1 1 eine form der
auseinandersetzung zu sein ich habe
immer davor gewarnt dass diese art von
ironie von satire ein ganz schmaler grat
ist der wirklich von antidemokratischen
und auch rechten kräften ausgenutzt
werden kann und das ist jetzt passiert
also ist er innerhalb weniger stunden
auf diesen plattformen dann entsprechend
kommentiert wurden
und das war für mich absehbar und das
hat mich geärgert weil es quasi
alarmstufe rot schon vor wochen war und
jetzt ist es genau so gekommen und viele
sind auch sehr betroffen darüber aber
man hat es vorher sich denken können
offen gestanden
wer ist unser feind das virus das virus
ist unser feind nicht wir nicht wir
bürgerinnen und bürger sollten uns
anfeinden manchmal habe ich das gefühl
es geht auch gar nicht mehr tatsächlich
um corona oder nicht corona sondern es
geht darum seinen ganzen brass und erker
und seine aggression im netz
einfach abzuladen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren